y analizamos también otra arista de lo
que ha sido todo este conflicto también
para nuestra salud más romeros a la está
aquí para explicarnos qué implicaciones
tiene la ocupación de la central de la
ex central nuclear chernóbil por parte
de los militares
rusos marc deberíamos preocuparnos por
esto pues raúl la verdad es que decir
que el riesgo no existe es totalmente
imposible al final es agregar una cierta
inestabilidad a una zona que ya de por
sí es inestable pero tenemos una buena
hay una mala noticia cuál prefieres
primero escuchar yo creo que prefiero
primero la buena porque ya hemos tenido
bastantes malas marc bueno la buena
noticia es que la zona de más alto
riesgo de chernóbil ahí donde sucedió el
accidente donde había la planta está
cubierta por una especie de sarcófago de
cemento y de hierro que es más grande
que el estadio de wembley para que nos
hagamos una idea de las dimensiones con
el objetivo de inactivar esta radiación
que surge de la zona más contaminada de
chernóbil durante al menos 100 años es
algo una estructura muy resistente y
algo muy grave debería pasar que esto se
tambaleara o dejará pasar la radiación
por ejemplo no sé que fuera bombardeada
directamente algo que por ahora parece
bastante improbable que suceda entonces
hay esta estructura que de alguna manera
protege la zona más contaminada de la de
chernóbil la mala es que la noticia mala
es que este daño no se extiende se
extiende más allá de lo que está tapado
de lo que está cubierto y toda la zona
llamada la zona de exclusión también
está contaminada y de hecho es por eso
que la agencia nuclear ucraniana ha
dicho que ha notado unos niveles más
altos de radiación en la zona aunque
todavía no habían aumentado a niveles
críticos esto puede deberse a todo el
movimiento que ha habido alrededor que
puede ser que levante una cosa llamada
polvo radioactivo que son como pequeñas
partículas todavía contaminadas que
quedan del accidente de
1986 así es marc y también pues hay una
serie muy buena al respecto en hb o que
si no se la han visto se las
recomendamos para entender también un
poco más de lo que sucedió ahí como
explotó este reactor nuclear mar pero le
pregunto si nada más debemos
preocuparnos por chernóbil pues sigue
siendo una mala noticia la realidad es
que no en realidad en chernóbil de eso
eso es lo que dicen las voces de
expertos al menos
planta nuclear que hay una ucrania que
debería preocuparnos menos las que más
nos deberían preocupar son las que están
en activo ucrania como ven tiene cuatro
plantas nucleares en activo hay dos que
están más cerca de leópolis que es una
zona que todavía está bastante calmada
en este momento y hay dos que están algo
más cerca de odessa y del río dniéper
que se prevé que sea una de las líneas
de combate no de esa ya han habido
ataques así donde las zonas bajo fuego
ucranios bastante grandes decir que no
es que estén en riesgo ahora mismo pero
están en zonas más cerca de lugares
donde han habido combates son plantas
nucleares activas por lo tanto el
desastre podría ser mucho mayor si llega
a suceder algo en esas en esas regiones
porque un desastre mar cómo funciona una
planta nuclear por favor denos luz sobre
esto para entender los riesgos que
conlleva debemos entender qué es lo que
sucede dentro de estos lugares no una
una planta nuclear lo que hace es
dividir el núcleo de elementos que son
inestables como el uranio se rompe este
núcleo de los átomos de estos elementos
y esto produce tres cosas produce
energía por un lado produce radiación y
también produce residuos radioactivos
como por ejemplo el estroncio
el bario esta energía se usa para dar
electricidad a través de una serie de
sistemas de turbinas y de agua y vapor
pero por ejemplo todos estos residuos no
hay manera todavía de reciclarlo son
residuos que pueden ser radioactivos
durante centenares incluso miles de años
y por ahora la única solución que hemos
encontrado es enterrarlos en unos
cementerios como de cemento especial es
entonces recordar también que en todas
esas plantas que hemos visto en el mapa
anterior pues también hay unas zonas de
residuos donde se almacena todo este
material radioactivo marc le pregunto
qué pasa si hay un accidente nuclear a
lo mejor como el que vivimos también en
chernóbil si eso es bueno lo primero que
pasa es que las personas el medio
ambiente quedan expuestas a la radiación
la radiación son los rayos que surgen
también de esta fisión nuclear que
estábamos hablando y que daña el
material genético de las células
entonces eso que conlleva a corto plazo
puede provocar lesiones cutáneas por
ejemplo en la piel como quemaduras
también puede provocar el síndrome de
irradiación aguda que de hecho es de lo
que murió mari curie una de las
ganadoras del premio nobel en qué
consiste es una enfermedad especialmente
cruel daña los tejidos de los órganos y
pues hay unos primeros síntomas que
luego pueden remitir como diarreas
vómitos pueden haber unas horas incluso
semanas en las que se sienta mejor la
persona y luego que se dañó todavía
aumente más problemas con la sangre
problemas respiratorios
cerebrovasculares para llevar incluso
hasta la muerte a largo plazo lo que
sucede es que aumenta el riesgo de
cáncer se calcula que entre el 3 y el 5
por ciento y también hay un especial
riesgo pues en caso de los niños y los
fetos puede provocar abortos espontáneos
y puede provocar daños en el feto pues
de crecimientos o incluso también de
deformación es lo mismo que pasó
entonces en chernóbil le podría pasar
ahora a marc pues la verdad desde el
análisis que estamos haciendo es más
bien no sobre todo porque hemos
aprendido mucho desde entonces
repasemos qué es lo que ocurrió como
decías antes y si no vean se la serie
como decía a raúl este accidente sucedió
en 1986 fallo un reactor explotó con una
fuerza 200 veces mayor a la bomba
nuclear de hiroshima por ejemplo y
afectó a tres países ucrania sobre todo
y también rusia entre las primeras
personas que respondieron a esta
emergencia se calcula que murieron unas
50 por ejemplo los bomberos que
acudieron a apagar el incendio que
estuvo nueve días quemando y luego pues
en las cifras de los efectos a largo
plazo hay mucho disenso el foro de
chernóbil calcula que son 9000 las
muertes atribuibles a este a este
accidente por cáncer la agencia
internacional de investigación del
cáncer en cambio tiene unas cifras que
oscilan desde las 6 mil hasta las 38 mil
un rango muy amplio y greenpeace llega a
calcular que podrían ser entre 93 mil o
200 mil las muertes asociadas a este
riesgo que ocurre en chernóbil en cambio
también tenemos un accidente como el de
fukushima que pasó más recientemente
hace apenas unos diez años y en ese
momento se ha visto que pues también por
la más rápida respuesta que hubo este
accidente todavía lado ms no es capaz de
decir que haya habido un aumento de los
casos de cáncer en esa región de japón
entonces eso nos puede dar indicaciones
de que a pesar de que hubiera un
accidente probablemente estamos mucho
más preparados para responder a ello y
por supuesto ojalá que nunca vuelva a
pasar
una tragedia como estas
es dolorosa saber cómo te vas se va
degenerando tus células está generando
todo y pues morir es la estabilización
incluso que genera respecto a las zonas
no en fukushima ni siquiera ha habido un
daño tan grande a la salud humana pero
hay personas que ya ni siquiera quieren
vivir ahí que no quieren comprar los
productos que se venden ahí entonces eso
también es algo que tenemos que tener en
cuenta por todo el temor que esto genera
mar muchísimas gracias como siempre por
toda la información y pasamos ahora a
saludar a nuestra segunda mitad del día